And I want to welcome you to today's special event, which is about shadow, and I called it a shadow of doubt, and there will be a very, very specific reason for that.
And I want to present here some ideas where I think it's a really interesting view of shadow and also how Jung saw shadow, because a general problem with Jung is that he has multiple definitions for the same thing, and you kind of have to pick up which one he has.
For example, unconscious has many, many, many different definitions depending on the context, and I want to give an additional one. But for this, first, I want to start with the more known definitions of shadow that people are familiar with. And, uh, before I start anything new.
So when we talk about shadow, very often what people know, have in mind, or have read before is something like the dark side within us. As the shadow is dark, there's some dark, evil, repressed things inside of us. As bad thoughts, bad ideas, evil actions, all these different things.
This is very similar to the Freudian idea of the psyche, that you have certain things inside you, some drives that are not really conforming to society, so they get repressed down and people become then very docile and very nice and all these different things. But there's this dark side.
Inside of them that could break out and does break out under certain circumstances.
And I chose here the picture of the book of Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde, where you have the perfectly fine Dr. Jekyll and he has this alter ego, this bad person inside of him, which is Mr. Hyde, who does horrible, horrible things if, when Dr. Jekyll does not pay attention.
So we're talking there about very negative things, cruel things, also very animalistic. So let's say less than human in its whole approach and appearance.
So we are talking here about, let's say, a simpler form of human, more driven by drives and very, very much against norms of society. In its actions. And this is what many people know. And when they hear, ah, I need to integrate my shadow, this is then what's associated with, ah, I need to find assertiveness. I need to be more assertive.
I'm way too agreeable and I need to be aware that I can be a horrible person and I have horrible thoughts and how to integrate that and how to think about that. So this is what most people know. This is one definition by, by Jung, most certainly. There's the another one, which is kind of the opposite of the ego.
So as soon as people become more familiar with Jungian thought and like basic Jungian premises or concept that he really likes and he really applies to many, many different fields, you come into contact with the opposite. So he really separates out the world, let's say, always into opposites. Where when things move and change, it's between them.
For example, male, female, conscious, unconscious. Also the different functions of cognition, thinking, feeling, sensation, intuition. Jung really likes to do the opposites, spiritual, earthly, and modern, primitive, stuff like that. So what you have there is everything that the ego is not.
Is then the opposite, and it's then in the shadow. And this is why it shows, uh, the picture here of a soldier and, uh, a hippie, because here in this case, one is the shadow of the other. One has the qualities, the worldview, and the behavior that the other one is lacking.
So this view of, about shadow is already very more sophisticated because it's not only, oh, the shadow is something negative. But rather the shadow is that what am I missing? And this is where my psychological, uh, development and change will take place in the future.
So there's parts of my personality and qualities of my personality that are hidden in the dark of my psyche, in the shadow of my psyche. And the psyche kind of tries to make me aware of that by For example, giving a special numinosity about the other, the missing part.
So very likely those two guys in the picture will have very bad opinions about each other, but it would be most helpful for them if they would learn about each other and find them there. So this is then not the, ah, shadow is evil, but rather shadow is everything that I'm not. And there can be a lot of positive things.
In my shadow, which I have not, uh, integrated, or that will be integrated. This is then where psychologists talk about the golden shadow to say, oh, there's opportunity there. And now the topic for today is talking about a new approach, third approach, saying, ah, there's a certain way how Jung talks about shadow, and it's super interesting.
And I want to go into that. But the first thing I want to do is a little bit drawing the structure of the psyche, how Jung sees it and how Jung says how we are constituted inside. Also to give a little bit of reference, he uses some terms like shadow, anima, animus, or the Self. And just to help, okay, where are we?
Because it is a very intricate system and it's very hard to map. And I tried here. And what I can say is like every drawing that you see or diagram that's trying to explain Jungian psychology is wrong in its own way. It's completely right as it is, but there's enough stuff surrounding that where one could say like, this is missing and this is not completely wrong.
And, but I tried here. So what we have here is really our ego. This is what I mentioned before. This is our awareness, the things that we can perceive and get to us. And around it is consciousness. Consciousness is everything that we know and we can do.
And consciousness forms naturally around our ego because, for example, when you learn something, it's connected through you experiencing it. If you see a plane crash or a crazy thunderstorm, It's you perceiving it and becomes your memory. So it becomes part of your consciousness.
When you learn how to play the guitar, you have the experience of having the strings on your fingers and on the frets and all these different things. And this becomes integrated into your psyche, in your consciousness. It becomes available to you. This is very much what ego and consciousness is. It's available. It's active. It's you. It's when you talk about yourself.
For example, a job interview, or you're meeting someone for the first time, you say, hi, I am that, I like this, I have done this. It's always I, I, I. This is why it's ego there. And this is also the basis of our perception. And everything outside of consciousness is the unconscious. This is the definition. Very easy.
Everything that's not conscious is unconscious, and that's everything in the world and everything inside of us. But Jung sees there a kind of layered approach that there's different layers in the psyche that you penetrate through the psychological development. And what you first perceive, which is not you, is in the Jungian view, always the shadow.
But that makes it also very hard to pinpoint down the shadow because Jung says everything below that as a layer. Is also perceived as the shadow because we only perceive one thing.
It's a little bit complicated thought, but the unconscious, the other part of our psyche that's not yet there, yet integrated in our consciousness, is represented by a single figure, which does not mean it's only that figure, but also everything behind it. So in the shadow, we have anima, animus, and we also have the Self.
Which makes the shadow also a little bit confusing, but you're penetrating then through time and integration of the different figures and spheres. And there's also where we have the layers of the psyche, uh, in regards to the personal unconscious and the collective unconscious.
So what we have here is a basic structure of the psyche, and the very important part is how we perceive it, how the psyche is presented to us and how the unconscious is presented to us. Here I want to go a little bit more deeper into the really personification of the unconscious. So what I've had a, now a diagram for, which is a little bit helpful because it's more visual.
Jung has here in a quote that is now in his, in his own words, and I will quote, therefore we are again and again up against the bewildering phenomenon that is the shadow. The anima, or the wise man, or the great mother, for instance, expresses the whole collective unconscious.
Each figure, when you come to it, expresses always the whole, and it appears with the overwhelming power of the whole unconscious. Of course, it is useless to talk of such experiences if you have not been through them. But if you have ever experienced one of such figures, You will know of what I'm speaking of.
One figure fills you with the holy terror of the unconscious. It is usually the shadow figure, and you fear it not because it is your particular shadow, but because it represents the whole collective unconscious. With the shadow, you get the whole thing.
Now, inasmuch as you are capable of detaching the shadow from the unconscious, if you are able to make a difference between the fish and the lake, If you can catch your fish without getting the whole lake, then you have won that point. But when another fish comes up, it is a whale, a whale dragon that will swallow you. With every new fish you catch, you pull up the whole thing.
So this is a little bit of what I've already talked about. The shadow representing also the collective unconscious, the collective unconscious being the instinctual part, the very human part, which connects us to all humans that are living right now, have lived, and will ever live. Where we could say, oh, this is really human nature. This is also where the archetypes are.
If you're interested in archetypes, they're always in the collective unconscious. And the shadow being then a representative of that. Makes this complicated in the sense of it is not only the opposite of you. This is when I showed the, the soldier and the hippie. It's pretty clear what their connection is, that they are the opposites of each other personality-wise.
But in the collective unconscious, you have then way more, like you have all the impersonal stuff also. And this again can be confusing about the shadow because this is all associated with that. So when you encounter the shadow, and this is a very nice thing about Jungian psychology, you will encounter your own psyche and everything that you're missing.
And you can, can do that in many, many different ways. This can be in dreams, visions, in everyday life, through synchronicities and fantasies, ideas, random thoughts that pop up. Or in culture very much.
Jung saw culture as an expression of our psyche, and it's a kind of dream theater where you have these different parts of the human psyche interacting with each other, and we are watching this because this is also very much closely matching what we are experiencing inside of us in regards to psychological development and interaction of the different parts.
So Jung says these contents that are not yet in our consciousness, that are not associated with us, that are not integrated, appear to us as a figure, meaning they are their own thing. They're autonomous. They act on their own. They have their own agenda. They have their own way of communicating, talking.
This is why you can have these weird phenomena that you can have a dream. That tells you stuff that you do not know. You were not aware of it. Your psyche was aware of it. Your unconscious was aware of it, but your consciousness wasn't. So you're encountering then that, and the psyche brings it up, presents it to you, and tells you something about yourself that you did not know.
And this is a very confusing part because a dream or a fantasy is hyper, hyper, hyper subjective. It's only you there. It's only you experiencing your psyche, experiencing yourself. And this is what Jung says, that everything in the dream is you. When you dream of persons, when you dream of situations, that is all you. You are experiencing yourself.
And one of those figures that you encounter is the shadow. And he explains a little bit more about to hone down How to know whether it's your shadow or not. So for example, this quote: shadow, which is always the same sex as the subject. This is something very useful to know.
So this is why, for example, I chose the picture of the soldier and the hippie, both male, because the shadow, as we're experiencing it and as we're projecting it onto other people or figures, is then very much with the sex that we are having. If it would be the opposite sex, it would be then more of an anima-animus problem, but we will stick with the shadow for now.
But another quote: Personification always indicates an autonomous activity in the unconscious. If some personal figure appears, we may be sure that the unconscious is beginning to grow active. The activity of such figures very often has an anticipatory character. Something that the dreamer himself will later do is being done in advance.
Meaning, Jung says that psyche always tries to create a balance. The psyche pushes to you to become more centered, to become more complete, to become more whole.
But at the same time, that means encountering a lot of things that are uncomfortable, like the shadow, which is the, the unwanted parts of one, or the unknown parts, and the parts one does not want to deal with because it's very nice how it is right now, and everything else can be very upsetting.
So if it's already in the stage that something is autonomous acting upon us, it is kind of such a strong counterbalance that tries to bring us back in the middle that it can be a little bit overwhelming experience.
Jung talks, for example, in Dreams, when there's certain instincts, certain drives not being paid attention to, that they can appear as wild animals that chase us in the night. It's then again, we are kind of chasing ourselves. Our psyche is chasing itself and we are in the middle to experience that. And it's not only inside of us that we can experience such figures as a shadow.
It's also outside. And there's a very big part, projection. Projection meaning we are so blind about this content in ourselves that we kind of have to experience them outside of us. That's a huge part. I go back here of the Jungian idea of the psyche.
Your perception is filtered through your own psyche, meaning you very often will designate a strong emotional value to things on the outside that is not inherent in the things.
There are 10 billion million things in the world, but at the same time, there are certain things that really call out to you, that you're really interested in and you don't know why. Or you really, really hate them and you don't know why. And likely you don't want to know why, because you're happy just with hating specific persons, for example.
But Jung says, ah, this is not random. This reminds you kind of something in yourself that you do not want to be reminded of. And this is why the psyche kind of points it out. So when you have strong emotional values, For Jung, this is a way to go, especially negative emotional values, because the question is then why, why are you feeling this way?
And the Jungian approach very often is, ah, because it might be something that you do not like in yourself, or you do not want to experience in yourself. You don't want to be associated with that. It reminds you of something hurtful. This is already a beginning of a whole psychological journey.
This is then going through the dark night of the soul and coming out transformed on the other side. So this is what this quote is about. They project their own contents into others and judge them there. So this one-sidedness naturally leads into an unconsciousness of one's own condition, which is then, of course, projected.
Anything unconscious that lives with us is invariably projected. And this is also how projection ends. As soon as you become aware of it, like, oh, it's me. I'm the reason why I hate this person, for example. This is then when it stops. As soon as you become aware that it's actually you doing these things, it disappears.
This has been now explanations for and elaborations on the first 2 ideas of shadow, and I want to now move on to the third one, which is a subject for today, but this is shadow of doubt. So one way how to read Jung in my eyes with certain quotes about shadow is that he very much calls doubt shadow.
And it's then an interesting way how to integrate that in the psychological journey and Become aware of that because I think doubt is more approachable to most people. They're more familiar with that. And what I want to do here today is lay out an argument for that.
And of course you can be the judge of that, whether it's a good argument or not, but I will present evidence and I will go right into it with a quote from Jung himself in regards to living in the shadow, which is an interesting term.
We all know those people who live in the shadow, like the unfortunate bird who cannot enter a concert hall without stumbling over a chair and always has to cough during a pianissimo, or the person who congratulates the mourners at a funeral when he means to express his sympathy.
There are many such unfortunate beings who go through life falling into one hole or the other, and if one asks them about their shadow, They inform one that they are murderers, cutthroats, and gamblers, and everything that is wrong, while in reality they are entirely decent folk.
If one takes away that film of illusion about their own shadow, one discovers 80% true gold, perfectly nice people. It's a surprising experience to discover that. So this was one of the quotes that brought me into the direction and the idea to set up this event and talk about shadow in this new and different way.
And I chose a picture here of, of Ross from Friends. And I think reading that, the picture is pretty clear that one has about the people who live in the shadow. They seem to be very self-conscious. They seem to be very unsure and they seem to have also, let's say, accidents.
Slip of tongue or physical accidents, which Jung says is a very strong sign that there's something not in harmony with the psyche. As I said before, the psyche tries to make us aware of certain things, and it does so also through our own body.
This can be regarding certain ailments of the body or through accidents. So when we have complexes, unresolved knots of the psyche, let's say, or in this case, the shadow, that people very feel much not at ease. They're very doubtful. They're very doubtful about themselves and even their good qualities. They have very, very low self-esteem.
So these would be words we would be using today that I think are a little bit more approachable. But I want to get deeper into that because when we live life filled with doubt. Jung has more quotes about that. The shadow is a negative of the conscious personality. This is what we had before with the soldier and the hippie.
But it may be much more decent and may have many more positive qualities than the conscious. For many people, if the dark side is the conscious, the conscious life and the shadow life. Such people are always putting the wrong foot forward. You know, people often look much more stupid than they really are, though usually it is the other way around.
And also, of course, there are other people who do not see the good in themselves, who live always below their own mark. Such people are possessed by the unconscious because they omit to see their good qualities. They explain them away because they are so used to seeing themselves in a negative light. They live in the shadow.
They are those unfortunate birds that always put the wrong foot forward. They twist everything they do into something indecent and say, of course I am a pig. Of course it is all wrong. Again, we have very much doubt, low self-esteem, high self-consciousness. And Jung says this is not actually the place to be. Jung says this is kind of switched around.
Normally, he says, consciousness is very much self-assured of itself because when you perceive your own psyche and it's filtered through your psyche, but also your consciousness, and you have a kind of consciousness, and this is normally for consciousness that only perceives what it can perceive, you kind of think you're perceiving everything.
Which means, oh, I can explain everything. So this you have in a lot of ideologies, or when people have like manic ideas and so on, that they're completely sure they know how the world works, how the world is, and there's no surprises and everything can be explained away. This is normally the state of consciousness.
This is very, very confidence through ignorance and incompleteness.
And this is when, when the psyche has to push against and remind people, hey, actually you don't know everything, and actually you are very much incomplete, and you should rather be humble and yeah, think about yourself, introspect about your experiences and about yourself.
So this is an also interesting enough, when Jung talks about when people live without their shadow. So that people have, I will quote him here, a shadow is a negative dark. So one uses the word in a sort of metaphoric way in order to designate such shadowy qualities. Anyone who is unaware of his shadow is too wonderful, too good.
He has a wrong idea about himself. Meaning high confidence, high self-esteem, absolutely no doubt about themselves. Everything is right. Everything is going well. Everything is going according to plan. There's no darkness there. There's only light. It's pretty great.
So this is why I have Gaston here from Beauty and the Beast, because you can see it already in his face that he's very much sure of himself. There's absolutely no doubt in that face. So Jung talks about this further. You see, people who are not in possession of their shadow, who are not aware of their inferior shadow side may apparently be marvelously good people.
One cannot discover any flaw in them. They are as white as milk. They themselves say there is nothing wrong with them and everybody else is wrong. Again, this is the projection. What you don't see in yourself, you perceive outside. You project it onto people and say like, it's incredible how everybody is stupid and wrong except for me. But they are never wrong.
But such people are absolutely possessed by devils because they can deny their shadow. So they're unaware and unconscious of parts of their personality. And both of these people are not, let's say, so nice people to have around.
The people who are completely filled with doubt, that are completely unsure about themselves, and then the people who are really, really sure about themselves. And this is too much doubt or too little doubt. And what we rather want is like a well-rounded person, just going by what kind of people we would like to have around us, uh, in our vicinity.
People who are aware of their different parts and sides. And first I want to talk about a case study that, that Jung gave, and it's a case study from 100 years ago.
It's about Richard Wagner, where he says, okay, Wagner is typical for, let's say, a maniac person, an artist, someone who has to be very, very much sure about themselves.
And the sense of when you do something and you put yourself out into the world, you have to, a kind of very strong confidence, extrovertedness, naivety about things that makes you very brave. The braveness of the naive.
Being, let's say, not completely aware of themselves helps, at least Jung says that, and it helped in the case of Wagner. The usual characteristic of the great man, the genius, is that he does not know he has a shadow. But he has, and a very ridiculous one.
Wagner, for instance, never realized while he was sitting there writing about Siegfried that he was revealing his own shadow for anyone who cared to look at him. He wore a crinoline while hammering out the Sword of Siegfried. In a dressing gown tied with pink ribbons, he wrote the Nibelungenlied, and he made himself a perfect ass. But such a man cannot admit he has a shadow.
He's never grateful to God for giving him his mind, but he assumes that he is his creative mind, that he has done all it himself. As soon as you see your own shadow and admit that you are not perfect, you cannot identify yourself with a great wise man and create a puer aeternus with your anima.
So it seems to help when doing very great things to be kind of full of yourself and without your shadow, at least not being aware of it.
And this is then very interesting in the context where the name shadow comes from and what it means colloquially, because Jung was very keen on using very colloquial terms to explain his psychological concepts. Like, everybody knows what a shadow is in normal life.
What he did not like so much about psychology and psychotherapists and so on, and big parts of his field, was that they were very often hiding behind, for example, Latin terms. And he did not really use that a lot. There's a very specific reason why he shows shadow, because in psychology we call the shadow the inferior figure bound to the earth.
It is just like the actual shadow that is always lying on the earth too. The term shadow should be taken literally, so to speak. The notion of the shadow was taken directly from the psychology of the primitives. Again, we have to be a little bit careful. Primitives has a very negative connotation today.
Jung talks about pre-scientific superstitious people, meaning not a special group of people, but rather a certain state of psychology. This was more prevalent in the past, but is still within us very much. So things become three-dimensional through a shadow. They're not flat on the wall. This is what Jung said before.
It's not somebody who is completely flat, but rather has an edge to them, has a little bit of depth. We already use these terms a lot when we describe people or we describe characters and stories. Ah, there's a very deep character. Yeah, they're really 3D characters and so on. And this is interestingly enough then through the shadow, similar as in school.
It was amazing when you found out that you can make a flat letter look 3D. Through a couple of lines by giving it again a shadow. The same happens then psychologically-wise, that things become more plastic and more real to us when we add a shadow. So this is then when we talk of a complete person.
Being there, very important that completeness does not mean wholeness. Interestingly enough, when we watch, for example, movies and especially famous movies, you have complex characters who show different contradictory traits and complex behaviors and all these different things. So you, you already map out the shadow in there.
And I put here the picture of, of Tony Stark, of Iron Man, mainly for my mother, but also because it's interesting that like one of the biggest movie franchises that existed in human history. Is all centered around a person who's confronting their shadow part.
Here's the arms dealer that realizes the harm that he's doing and tries to become the hero saving people with his knowledge instead of being, let's say, only a playboy. So it's interesting that you have a lot of contrast in the personality.
It's, uh, then really a play between the opposites and its integration of the shadow and Now he's being paid an incredible amount of money to come back because he realized, oh, they don't have characters like that anymore. So it's interesting that people are drawn to certain figures that represent certain psychological circumstances.
So, and I want to talk about this a little bit more, a complete person, not a flat person on the wall, but really a 3D person. That we are drawn to in our vicinity, but also how we ourselves like to be, mainly, and how our psyche actually pushes us to develop in that way. Because that's a very confusing thing about the psyche.
The psyche wants a lot of things from us, but the communication is rather lacking. So it's mostly stuff happening to us and we have to kind of figure it out. And this is where Jung really helps because he's been mapping that. Through his whole life. So I want to get into it. Wholeness is not as much perfection as completedness.
Assimilation of the shadow gives man a body, so to speak. The animal sphere of instinct, as well as the primitive archaic psyche, emerge into the zone of consciousness and can no longer be repressed by fictions and illusions. In this way, man becomes for himself the most difficult problem he really is.
He must always remain conscious of the fact that he is such a problem if he wants to develop at all. Repression leads to a one-sided development, if not stagnation, and eventually a neurotic dissociation. This is what I meant before. In consciousness, everything seems very clear, very orderly. Everything is known and decided and these different things.
And if a person acts like that, without a shadow, without a doubt, they're very hard to be around because they never see themselves at fault. They never doubt themselves.
And Jung says it will not only be tough for them, let's say, to find friends and interact with others, but also the psyche will constantly push against that and say like, you're not as great as you think you are. Of course, this can go to the completely other side when you completely live in the shadow, like Ross.
Being completely unsure and very doubtful and not even aware of your good qualities. It has to be both. You have to be aware of the good and the bad qualities at the same time, making it very, very hard. And this, with a man becomes for himself the most difficult problem, also ties very nicely with Nietzsche. Jung was a huge fan of Nietzsche.
He had an incredibly long seminar he gave on Thus Spoke Zarathustra. And there's a famous quote by Nietzsche about, you try to find the heaviest burden and you found yourself, which is an interesting way to look at it. And this is psychology. So if a person is more or less complete, his shadow side is visible.
If it is not, you feel that person is painted flat upon the wall with more or less shadow. There are more or less negotiation or contradiction. And without that, nobody is complete. People who have only two dimensions are identical with a sort of persona or mask, which they carry in front of themselves and behind which they hide. The persona in itself casts no shadow.
Persona, meaning the role that we have in the world, the way how we are perceived. For example, when you're a policeman and you're only a policeman, or you're a a mother and you're only a mother. This is then the persona. This is what people can see from, from outside.
And it's, let's say, very easy to hide the complexity of one's own psyche behind that, behind a function, let's say. And people notice. That's the thing. You don't notice your shadow, but everybody else does. This is also why Jung says the easiest way to find out about your shadow is just to ask other people what's wrong about yourself or what you don't know about yourself.
Which is an interesting experience, to say the least. But what we're talking about here, integration, development, Jung has a term for that, and that term is called individuation, which is the individual journey one takes through one's psyche, through one's life, and expressions one's psyche through time.
And the integration of the shadow, of course, is called shadow integration. And for the idea to say that the shadow is associated with doubt and having too much doubt or having no doubt is a bad position to be in. It's important to take doubt into consideration.
And we have the smartest person who lived at Greece at the time, Socrates, being told that by the Oracle of Delphi, has this very famous quote, I know that I know nothing. This is already a doubtful position.
It's not a bad idea to start from that point for one's own psychological development, to be humble and to be doubtful about oneself. Not too doubtful, not to be Ross, but to be questioning oneself. So how would it look like, this integration of the shadow? Because I talked before, it's a, it's a figure.
It's a representation of psychological contents that you encounter in your life, in your dreams, in your psyche. And Jung says the integration is interesting in the sense of that it's a relationship. You're kind of building a relationship with yourself, with different parts within you.
This is why he says in this quote, there is no general effective technique for assimilating the shadow. It is more like diplomacy or statesmanship, and it is always an individual matter. First, one has to accept and take seriously the existence of the shadow, the existence of the other part one is not aware of.
Second, one has to become aware of its qualities and intentions, meaning Is it good quality? Is it bad quality? That happens through conscientious attention to moods, fantasy, and impulses. Again, perceiving ourselves in the psyche, inside, outside, dreams, persons that we have strong emotional reactions to.
Third, a long process of negotiation is unavoidable. This is kind of a process that has to be lived through again and again. It is, Jungian psychology is very, very dynamic. Things constantly shift, constantly change, and it kind of needs a maintenance that's going on.
Just like a normal relationship that you have with any other person. When you're friends or partner with someone, that's not it. You have to keep it up. And same way, you have to be Checking in with yourself, let's say, and with the different things that you are maybe not aware of right now.
So interestingly enough, we have this then also in movies, also with the opposites as said before, but also then with this doubt that you have two characters that learn about themselves through other people that are very different from themselves. And I have here some examples from The Men in Black or from Crazy Stupid Love or from Rush Hour.
And it is, it's interesting to see how even the facial expressions are very, very similar, but you become aware of the ways how you are incomplete, especially in Crazy Stupid Love. You have this very, very sure of himself Ryan Gosling character, and then you have Steve Carell who kind of has to learn how to deal with women. And both learn from each other, right?
Both are incomplete in their own way, but they complete each other through a relationship. And this is a very important part about shadow integration or any kind of integration. The parts are projected outwards.
That means you kind of build a relationship then with this person, but you not only have then a relationship with this person, but you build the relationship with yourself in a way. So shadow integration has to do with another person. But this not only makes good between you and the person, but kind of makes good inside of you.
It's everything very, ah, physical again with, with, with Jung. And similar then at the next step for anima and animus, this then with the opposite sex. So the first one can be a friend with a shadow. The other one is then rather with a partner, with a long-term stable relationship.
And this is then also where things would progress towards if we would say, okay, now we became aware of our shadow. We are aware of its qualities. We're constantly negotiating. We're exchanging gifts and compliments. What is happening then psychologically? Because I want to go into that also. What is the stage beyond shadow integration?
Our consciousness becomes larger. Now we have the shadow and it's kind of in our consciousness, it's integrated, it's part of it. And we are now, let's say, completely aware and have fully mapped our personal unconscious.
So the things in our conscious that are personally related to us and that were before in the shadow, that where the psyche sent the figure of the shadow to us to make us aware of these things, this is now all there. But the unconscious does not stop. It's just that we now perceive other parts of the unconscious more clearly.
This part of the unconscious is the collective unconscious. And this is anima and animus. And this is when it becomes super freaky. And this is where it becomes very, very hard to explain what this is actually. What is the anima? What is the animus? And what are their expressions expressing because they're kind of functions.
And also the collective unconscious, that's a scary part to become aware of all the impersonal things inside your psyche that you're not aware of, or like that you cannot really comprehend. And I think the easiest way and the easiest way to explain it is emotions. Emotions are highly, highly impersonal.
Fear, anger, lust, joy, all these different things kind of grip a person and drag them in a certain direction. And we, in these situations, are so identified with that that we think, oh, this is us. And actually it's not really. And it's then especially dangerous when we blindly act out anger, for example.
So a well-integrated person still feels anger, but they do not act on that. They are, let's say, socialized enough not to just blindly act out their anger. It's still inside of them, but it's not being acted out. And to have this awareness that this is actually pretty impersonal and does not, like, anger does not care about you.
Fear does not care about you. And the other drives also. And this, you would now have to go even deeper into anima, animus, and also collective unconscious where you have the whole history and psychological development of humanity at itself, which would be a bit too much for today.
But I kind of wanted to hint at that, what lies beyond the shadow if one build that relationship because then you hit the anima, animus problem. And Jung points out why it's so important to move beyond the shadow, to move beyond the point where you think it's all personal in your unconscious.
I should like to emphasize that the integration of the shadow or the realization of the personal unconscious marks the first stage in the analytic process, and that without it, a recognition of anima and animus is not possible.
The shadow can be realized only through a relation to a partner, the anima, and animus only through a relationship to a partner of the opposite sex, because only in such a relation do their projections become operative. And also, if he really sees his shadow, If he realizes the unconscious qualities of his personality, the anima cannot possess him.
But as long as either the anima or the animus has that uncontrollable power, you can be sure that such people are not enough aware of their shadow. Again, I want to show it from the beginning, because what people perceive first is their shadow with everything lying behind.
And you cannot realize and perceive what's lying behind if you did not do the first steps and got beyond that screen. This is not the end of the journey. This is then the beginning of a completely new journey. But suddenly the, your psychology shifts and how you perceive the world and how you perceive yourself. And this makes it then also very hard to explain those things.
Jung was very much a Gnostic, and gnosis comes from knowing. So you have an experience, it is undeniable, you cannot make sense of it, and this is how many, many people come to Jung because he dealt his whole life with that, trying to make sense of these very strange insights and experiences that people have.
And this is then also what this event is about, how a psychological journey would look like. And I want to thank you very much for your time and attention for this very special topic of shadow.
And I hope I done my case well explaining and giving insight into the psychological phenomenon of the shadow and how it plays into our lives and how it can be encountered and dealt with.